now you've been in an industry for many
years sure yeah yeah one of this you
take on these really strong roles and I
really have to ask you because you've
been there for so long this big movement
this year and last year with the me to
times up
equal pay all of that what does it mean
for you to hear that the industry is
finally changing
yeah and it's finally being heard and
does that make you reflect on your own
experience yeah I think this is a really
excellent time for everyone for women
for minorities for everyone because what
it's asking of us it's asking us to do a
better job it's also setting an example
to the rest of the world so we are in
effect creating change all over the
world in other markets you know we're
talking about academia we're talking
about Wall Street we're talking about
everything we're saying this is the
standard of behavior we're taking sex
off of the bargaining table now a lot of
your fans from Castle I mean you put
your name on social media now it's you
know it's you from castle do you miss
anything about that show I mean this is
much darker as you mentioned do you miss
any aspect of that yeah running for
eighth season right yeah I worked for
eight seasons with a crew of people and
a production of people that became more
than just co-workers we got to witness
you know births I mean not I wasn't in
the room or anything like that but I was
in the vicinity yeah that's all the
ratio or go to the hospital if they had
fallen sick or whatever you hear a part
of each other's lives so I miss that but
I also miss the sort of fan reaction to
this show we had an amazing group of
fans an amazing audience they were
diehards
and so I think that was a real like
privilege to be able to sort of
entertain that group of people no
response
I got to see your show last night and
I'm still a little bit nervous about the
whole thing I saw was so intense it's
it's beautiful and it's scary and
there's something that that's really
intriguing about it you take on this
character of Emily Byrne who's a kept in
captivity for six years how would you
describe Emily and what we're gonna
learn about her Wow so you know it's
Nordic style thriller so it's grounded
in reality in ish this story starts off
six years after she's been taken into
captivity and she was believed to be
dead so she was declared dead in
absentia that's the name of the story
and everything in the entire world in
her world has gone on so her husband is
remarried and the baby that they had
together is now grown up calling someone
else mom she comes back to a child who
doesn't know her and doesn't necessarily
accept her right away but I think that
you know genetics plays into it as we
move on and you see how much these two
have in common and how much of a force
of inspiration he was for her to survive
through six years of torture which we
discover later on yeah those torture
scenes you do your own stunts I
understand that yeah though I don't want
to ruin for anybody but the boys that
are you in the ball yeah no are you
close your full butt does any of that
you got tell me how do you shoot that
like I can't even imagine I'm assuming
there were retakes on that yeah oh yeah
they made it as safe as they could yes
and their mind over matter like yeah
Hey look getting the right take and
getting it really well on camera is it's
an it definitely motivates you and then
also not having to go underwater again
and hold your breath for you know ten
minutes that motivates ya
[Music]